c'est très très dur d'appréhender
quelqu'un qui souffre et qui lui-même
sait pas trop comment l'expliquer
cicatrices fin c'est vraiment très
difficile de trouver de l'aide comme
c'est encore très stigmatisés ces
maladies là toutes les maladies c'est
possible polarité et borderline et c'est
moi franchement je préfère que ça soit
tombé sur moi que sur quelqu'un d'autre
de ma famille
[Musique]
y'a pas une schizophrénie à des
schizophrénies tout le monde à
développer une schizophrénie différentes
il ya plein de symptômes différents
après les plus gros symptômes seller
crise psychotique les angoisses et
psychotique
on peut aussi entendre des voix mais
tous les schizophrènes n'entendent pas
des voix pour mon cas personnel
cg d'impression g d angoisse de mort
plus plus plus j'ai l'impression que mon
monde va s'effondrer ou qu enfin il va
se passer un cataclysme chez thibault ça
se traduit par des hallucinations
auditives surtout des voix parasites et
la fatigue fatigue intellectuelle
émotionnel que ça engendre un gros
manque de motivation pour regarder des
films en entier par exemple si tu vois
la difficulté de se prononcer les
canalisations d'attention a trop
longtemps
c'est ça j'ai vu après par exemple
vachement de mal à connecter aussi avec
les avec les autres du coup avoir un job
c'est compliqué les relations sociales
ouais général voilà ma mère a été très
très inquiètes mon frère il l'a jeu
consistait barricades et il s'est
renforcé il s'est rendu rssi je sais pas
si ça a été pareil pour toi moi j'étais
dans leur jeu ouais la peur et le rejet
omnicast comme ça un diagnostic qui tous
moi c'est ta vie qui change
on va moi j'ai toujours et voulu aller
de l'avant mais enfin ça tu as
l'impression un peu de ta vie s'écroule
aussi dans un certain sens parce que tu
dis est ce que je vais pouvoir avoir une
vie de famille est ce que je vais
pouvoir travailler
est ce que je vais pouvoir toujours voir
mes amis ce qu'ils vont pas mal le
prendre d'exclus fin des questions que
tout le monde se pose quand on nous
donne ce diagnostic là
[Musique]
30% des personnes en france sont gênés
s'ils font un repas de famille avec une
personne ayant une maladie pieds donc
c'est encore il ya encore des gros tabou
a levé par rapport à toutes les maladies
pied en plus particulièrement les
schizophrénies aussi un repas de famille
comme ça où mon père vient d'annoncer à
une partie de la famille qu'il a été
diagnostiqué schizophrène et 1 et d'un
coup ça modifie leur garde et de
l'entourage quoi il ya un truc de
méfiance et de kia de la méconnaissance
ya de la méfiance est aussi une espèce
de forme d'injustice parce que quand tu
te dis quand même c'est des gens qui ont
vu mon frère on dirait qu'on auprès des
quais de bus a grandi d'un coup tu vas y
à un regard pas forcément juge mais tu
t'y mets considéré comme un étranger
donc je sais pas ton point de vue mais
c'est vrai je pense que vous m'offrez
les créations de tout est magie perdure
en ciel sont chantés c'est très sérieux
aussi dans ma famille et c'est très dur
de de l'appréhender de au début ça fait
mal et après moi je me dis bon bah si
ces gens là ils pensent comme ça c'est
que ça ça vaut pas la peine
ça vous pas la peine je peux leur
expliquer expliquer ça vaut la peine ça
vaut la peine de l'expliquer mais je me
dis au début au québec personne
concernée surtout ça fait mal tout bas
ça fait mal je me blinde et ça fait mal
car non ça fait mal
[Musique]
on est proche c'est vraiment très
important pour j'ai un petit frère qui
m'épaule j'ai une mère qui m'épaule donc
je pense que le rôle de prof je pense
j'ai envie de te dire tu vois c'est
vraiment c'est quelque chose ton livre
elle est magnifique et c'est ce qui
monte c'est qu'une relation fraternelle
où relations mères filles soeurs frères
ou frère frère c'est super important ça
pouvant gérer la maladie au quotidien
deux fois